and he always told me to put money into  coaching because it's really important  to have someone that knows more than you  do and that you're always learning from  so a lot of people are afraid to get  like pay a lot of money for coaches or  give up control of their business to  hire something out but my dad is always  the first to tell you to like find  whoever is the best at something and  learn from them or hire them so that's  my dad's business advice and desirable  morival more he also told me that any  risks you want to do in business to do  it while you're young because life  changes and then you have kids and a  family and you just never know how in  the long run your life is going to  change and if you can afford to make  business risks so he said when it's just  you  um to take as many risks as you can